Speaker 1: I want to give you another one
of these examples of Fox News casually mentioning,
oh, that story we covered for a week and told
you that we verified independently.
Turns out it was complete and total fake news.
The latest is from Maria BARTIROMO.
This is the story Fox News ran with for a
week last week about supposed homeless veterans
being kicked out of hotels in order to make
room for undocumented immigrants because of
something Biden did.
The story was totally made up.
Maria BARTIROMO waited an extra week before
casually updating us that the story was completely
made up.
Speaker 3: We want to update you on a report
last week claiming that upstate hotels in
Orange and Rockland counties, including the
Crosswords Hotel, Crossroads Hotel, evicted
a group of homeless veterans.
We've since learned that veterans advocates
misled local officials, and it now turns out
those eviction claims were false.
We want to update you on the story, make sure
the record was set straight, and we'll get
more to you as we get it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there you go.
What she means is it's fake news.
We reported fake news and angered people and
fired people up based on a story that's completely
imaginary.
And remember that Fox News said they verified
the story.
It's not.
Well, listen, someone reported this and we
were misled.
They claimed to have verified the story.
And what it sounds like is going on is Fox
News lawyers have said you might want to make
some kind of retraction about this.
We did talk earlier this week of Laura Ingraham
also casually mentioning, by the way, that
story was fake.
Speaker 3: All right, before we go, a little
update on a story we brought you this week
about.
Speaker 1: A little update being displaced
from.
Speaker 3: Hotels so that illegals could move
in.
Turns out the group behind the claim made
it up.
We have no clue as to why anyone would do
such a thing.
No.
We'll bring you any updates should they come.
Speaker 1: Why would and as I said on Monday,
why would anybody lie in order to try to support
their preexisting political narratives that
Biden is treating undocumented immigrants,
quote, better than Americans and veterans?
Why would why would anyone make that up?
And this was one other retraction that was
issued.
Speaker 2: Quick update on a story from earlier
this week about homeless veterans being displaced
from a hotel in Newburgh, New York.
Right.
To make room for migrants.
We're now looking into new reports that a
veterans advocate misled lawmakers about or
and media outlets about a story that some
homeless men may have been hired to pose as
veterans.
We don't have reached out to the organization
for a statement, but so far have not heard
back.
Speaker 1: It's all so hazy.
We just don't know what happened.
So there is Maria BARTIROMO shamelessly joining
those who say, listen, I don't know, we were
misled when you said you verified the story
that they don't mention anymore.
Completely and totally pathetic.
We'll see if any more retractions are coming.
We have such a great bonus show for you today
that I hope that you're already a member.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Yeah.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad.
Speaker 1: We will discuss on today's bonus
show the new study that finds 2 billion people
could be impacted by life threatening heat
by the end of the century.
We've talked about heat before, and I don't
mean Trump talking about applying light and
heat to cure.
I'm talking about heat and climate change
and the issues that it will bring forward.
This new study is very specific about where
these dangerous heat levels will be.
Secondly, in Texas, they are allowing unlicensed
religious chaplains to, quote, counsel students
as if they were therapists, but they are not.
This is the latest placating of the religious
right.
I don't even what the call, you know, what
they call them, the sort of Christian Sharia
type folks in Texas.
We will discuss it.
And U.S. colleges are now exploring what would
admissions look like if they were no longer
race conscious, which is we're talking about
affirmative action here.
This would be a major change in American college
admissions.
What would it mean?
What would it do?
What would the implications be?
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Can't wait for you to join us by simply signing
up at join Pacman dot com.